they've all seen Jurassic world at this
point right cool this is my spoiler talk
for Jurassic world this is for the fans
who have already seen me review the
movie they're like you know what I just
want to hear that talk about
more so here we are talking about a
movie I've already reviewed this is your
fun of the world right talking about
spoilers as I said in my review
Jurassic world there's an enjoyment to
be had in it because it's a really cool
monster man because the monster in the
movie is a cool monster and in the movie
they actually addressed that everyone in
the movies like dude you didn't need to
make the monster I love how the movie
addressed the corporate mindset versus
the consumer mindset what consumers want
they want more and more and more and
more like that Lake Placid on steroids
like eating jaws and kids
on the cell phone like that's right all
right tweets it's like a good message
because that's how the world is what's
cool one moment is cool only for a
moment and at that point people just on
to other things
it wasn't crazy as kill with that one
girl who was kind of babysitting the
kids who completely failed at being a
babysitter pterodactyl craps there's
just dunking her in the tank like he's
baptizing the out of her I was like
wait a minute
that thing comes up and eats the
pterodactyl is it gonna oh my god it's
gonna happen dozen shots like yeah she's
dead which I love that holy asuras
can cloak we wouldn't remember of the
loss were not the movie not the lost
world movie but the lost world book
there was a dinosaur that could cloak in
that what is this now kind of in the
movie and so it's just neat to see cuz
it's like predator but a dinosaur that's
scary
holy asaurus his nose would always
get down there next to Chris Pratt or
something reminded me at alien 3 not the
best alien movie ever but it reminded me
of a 93 that scene where Ripley's all
like to the side and aliens I like and
what I thought of anyway we gotta admit
Vincent d'Onofrio's character in the
movie is totally a cartoon he's all
Ranger wreck like we need to weaponize
velociraptors I was like this is the kid
who had died no writers that's right he
had those two I had those toys that's
funny enough I had the velociraptors it
was like he was blind with him he's like
that's my dream let's have Nathan Drake
make it a reality when I saw Chris Pratt
in this movie I was like it's totally
Nathan Drake he was wearing Nathan
Drake's shirt in this scene I was like
this is Nathan Drake audition tape so I
were here and there's one thing I didn't
get I mean I know that doctor woohoo
they made like dr. Frankenstein
in this movie you know what the dinosaur
was made out of Bryce Dallas Howard
didn't she's a cycle they make them and
we have them feel like you're just kind
of a shitty business person at that
point if you have someone who's making a
monster
you're not gonna question that
you're gonna really alright whatever
yeah sure we'll just you know sell it to
kids how dumb like it's the stupid thing
to do I feel like she should have known
what was in the dinosaur at which point
when Chris Price like let's use the
velociraptor she could've been like um
don't do that because alpha wolf is
gonna override Cesar Millan and now
you're so I guess in the movie
she didn't know so they were
there's a kick-ass fight at the end of
this movie
Godzilla fight at the end was cool
mean t-rex has his day in the Sun t-rex
looked old I was like is that like the
original Jurassic Park 1 t-rex very well
could've been al comes out like issues
my like yeah you are a seasoned bastard
go kick his ass go beat the out of
holy of Soros only should a source
get some really sweet heads in there
though t-rex kind of got his balls
kicked a bit twenties it was a really
cool fight I mean there was a t-rex
versus that big spinosaurus dinosaur in
the third movie but it's just kind of an
ass-kicking to show you like oh this
thing's just bigger and better this one
was nature versus nurture nature kinda
wins sometimes when it has help from a
velociraptor doesn't really say it
reminded me at the fight at the end of
Godzilla you're like let them fight
let's see if we wanted to see it we
wanted to see the dinosaur of old fight
the monster of new and is happening
and it is going down and Bryce Dallas
Howard ran wonderfully in her heels good
for her that's impossible that's
actually a modern marvel but then when
holy asaurus stands up and it kind
of backs up and it was next to the water
I was like oh ho deep blue sea deep blue
she's gonna get Sam Jackson for people
to see sure enough light Placid on
steroids comes up room she bites it and
I was like deep Lucy I don't really
spoken about the kids much at all
because they were kind of alright they
were in it you need kids but I just
wasn't attached to the kids I was like
alright you're a super genius kid and
you're kind of Stamos seeing out he
wasn't even Stamos hang out he was
creeping out of some girls a dude was
just staring he needs someone to run
from holy of Soros so why not put a
couple of kids out there guys in the end
just may surprise some people who are
gonna be like yeah I know you said that
other people are gonna be like what I
thought you tore the movie apart like
one dude
Twitter's that I on the movie weird
cuz I didn't really on my there's
enjoyment to be had in the monster movie
in any case point is are a lot of people
who love Jurassic world more than I
loved it I enjoyed it there are some
undeniably cool things in the movie are
also undeniably shitty things in the
movie like the characters just I can't
get over the fact that they irritated me
great a Jurassic world's not like a
character study movie you should be able
to just enjoy it as the movie it is and
that did I enjoyed it as the monster
movie it was which a Jurassic world I've
already asked you what you thought about
it but let's get more specific what's
your favorite thing about the movie in
least favourite thing about the movie
life is balance folks who's gotta be
both what do we think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you wanna see more
click right here to see more